so thanks a lot for coming to this talk
repairing for a future microservices
journey in November 2010 Thomas Thwaites
a designer from the UK gave a really
funny TED talk about his project that
accomplished before and this project was
called the toaster project and was about
his idea to build a toaster from scratch
so he went out and to his local
appliance store in and bought a very
cheap toaster for reengineering purposes
and he started to disassemble this very
cheap toaster and he was very surprised
that this very cheap toast of three
pounds 94 was consisting of four hundred
four different parts made of 100 plus
different materials since he does not
want to spell it doesn't didn't want to
spend the entire lifetime on this
toaster project he was focusing on five
materials steel mica copper plastic and
nickel and he went out on a quest for
those materials so he went to a remote
iron mine in the north to the north of
in the north of England and he came back
with a suitcase full of iron ore to
extract steer from he was also trekking
to the highlands of Scotland and
searched for mica and this entire
journey to build a saucer from scratch
was paved with a lot of failures and
setbacks but finally after nine months
he finished managed to finish this
toaster and the result looked like this
so you might ask yourself why am I
telling you about this toaster project
because in some kinds it was reminding
me of all the struggles and challenges
that come when starting the journey to
microservices so when starting the
journey to microservices you start was
identifying good candidates for micro
services modeled around a bigger
business capability you bounded context
where your domain model is in and for
each micro service they should they
supposed to own the state of their
domain model for that purpose we have to
address data storage components these
data storage components have to be
integrated into our micro services
have to be configured setups and also
maintained your micro services have to
be deployed on some kind of server
preferably packaged on top of a package
as a container you need to provide an
API for communication purposes and when
the service is communicating with
another service directly it needs to
integrate the service API we need to
consider security aspects in terms of
authentication authorization and
encryption we need to have service
discovery to which each service is
registered that services can be
discovered by other services to connect
to as soon as we run multiple instances
of one service we need to have an load
balancer that distribute the traffic and
workload since our micro services are
communicating over slow and unreliable
network we have to design for failure to
keep our system resilient so we have to
consider them to introduce stability
patterns such as timeouts handling and
retries to repeat an operation that
timed out with retries we also have to
make sure that our operations are
idempotent so that it's repeated call is
leading to the same outcome to preserve
partial functionality when failure
occurred we have to consider both heads
to protect our system against cascading
failure a circuit breaker helps us to
isolate the failure for revenge route
and service interaction we have to
provide a message broker that our
services can publish events to or
messages to that other services can
subscribe to and this message broker has
to be integrated into our services and
as a separate component we have to
configure and maintain this message
broker as well
we need an api gateway as a single point
of entry from there from outside and
since our micro service
only consisting of code but also of
configuration data we have to make sure
to provide an centralized configuration
management we need to consider
observability capabilities to generate
deep and standing of the health of our
system yeah and we also need a good repo
and a CI CD pipeline for service and
last but not least we also have to take
care of that we provide backup mechanism
and recovering mechanism and also enable
our services to be scaled up and scaled
down as well so to build one service you
have to take care of a lot of
infrastructure and operational
complexities and if you are planning to
build all these to handle all these
complexities by yourself
especially when you're small team was
little DevOps practices in place you may
might end up was compromises on things
that you should not compromise on
compromises with things that I will show
you later because the problem is that
yeah the problem is that you focus that
you cannot focus on your core domain
anymore that you can't build your core
made instead you're shifting your focus
handling these complexities and if you
handle these complexes all by yourself
you might end up with compromises on
things that could look like this that's
the product that took a very long time
to build it's very expensive and in this
case even not usable only for five
seconds before it was melting down due
to missing insulation so the question
now is how can a small team handle all
these infrastructure and operational
complexities that microservices come
with but still deliver user and business
value one approach is to focus on your
core domain and that distinguishes you
from your competitors and offload the
commodities that are not differentiating
of our component component from your
competitors to to someone else so we
need to shift the focus back handling
our core domain building our core domain
and that's the one that we should
surgically set strategically investment
that's the one that we should build
in-house since the codomain is the one
that hell fills user needs and generates
you visible user value leading to
satisfied customers and we can focus on
our core domain by offloading those
parts of our software that the commodity
is that not differentiating us from our
competitors to someone else by
outsourcing commodities to utility
supplier that leads to decreasing your
suffered the the delivery time for new
features and increasing the software
delivery performance leading to business
value and as Julie this morning already
mentioned in her keynote about the
accelerate book this accelerate box
Israel was doing a four years research
run by a Nicole foster ingest humble and
Jean Kim and then their four years
research they have they have revealed
that software delivery performance has a
strong impact on your productivity
profitability and market share so
software delivery performance is really
critical for technology organization
doing business today just a quick intro
to myself so Who am I so I am an
independent tech consultant and I am
coming from home work and I have
organizations technical complexities
from software architecture to suffer
delivery and I was previously working as
a start-up CTO and transforming the SAS
solution from one or two micro services
I presenting a tech conferences as here
has build stuff but also co organizing
some some conferences or being a program
committee member or track host so coming
back to the question how can we identify
what to build in-house and what to
outsource and that's where worldly Maps
come in so who have you have heard of
what limits before a few a few hands
great so oddly maps have been created by
Simon Wadley and Simon Wadleigh is a
researcher from the UK and he has
created this
this technique a worldly map is a
representation of the landscape
businesses operating in and it
visualized the evolution of a value
chain so the next question is what is a
value chain so behind every user need
there's a value chain and it starts off
with the first question yet who are you
users who are going to approach you and
searching for help and what are their
user needs what are the problems that
they would like to get solved by you and
what are the components and activities
that fulfills these user needs either
directly or indirectly by facilitating
other components and activities in the
value chain and then you also identify
what are the the dependency between
these components and activities and what
are their position in the value chain
itself so at the top we have those
components and activities that are very
visible to your users that's where your
users are touching your system and at
the bottom we have those components and
activities that are quite invisible to
your users after we have identified this
value chain with this appending
components activities in their position
in the beta chain we take it and plot it
along an evolution axis going from left
to right on the Left we have Genesis
with brand new things that have never
been sued before then custom build then
product and rental these are
off-the-shelf products or open source
software and then commodity and utility
on the on the right and the movement of
a component from left to right is
determined by its stage of evolution
what lay maps come with some patterns
I'm just scribbling a few of them so one
pattern is that nothing is static on the
map every everything is really really
dynamic and and everything evolves from
left to right through the forces of
demand and supply competition and while
component evolves from left to right
through its evolution stages the career
characteristics changes going from the
uncharted domain
the undefined uncertain unpredictable
constantly changing domain to the
industrialized domain on the right the
very mature market or the well known
commonly understood domain on the right
and there is no choice over evolution
and if you if you're not continuously
adapting you might get overtaken by
others efficiency enables innovation
that means that the industrialization of
one component and the sufficient
provision enables the innovation of
other components so for example that new
features of an existing product can
appear or that other components can Co
evolve all that new components can
emerge and abling new user needs and
it's the genesis of new components that
generates future source of value but
that's but there's also something that
holds you back and that's this inertia
to change and and success breeds inertia
so any path success that you have was a
component it tends to create reluctance
to changing that components and the more
successful you have been with a
component the the bigger the inertia
gets and it's also can kill an
organization so despite the fact it's
not it was not the lack of innovation
that harmed companies such as Nokia and
blockbuster but their inertia to change
that was one of the reason in fact Nokia
was very innovative that came out was
their first smart phone model two years
before ever came out with their iPhone
but they were very reluctant to change
to the smart phone era since they were
so successful with their old cell phone
model if you can still remember that one
and so that was creating a lot of harm
to Nokia and their market value declined
by over 90% within only six years so but
enough of the patterns just create an
example of for what limit and
that let's create an example of
something that you as an attendee of a
conference might have already interacted
with a conference solution so you are
the users as attendees and you might
have the user needs that are focused
around the schedule like browsing the
schedule by day or a filter of the
schedule by topic or creating your
personal schedule by marking those
sessions that you would like to attend
all the user needs thats related to
speakers like listing the speakers
displaying the speaker details or search
a speaker by name the feedback related
user need could be that you would write
rate a session or that you provide
feedback to the organizers by filling
out a survey or ticket related a user
need could be that you would like to get
the ticket print the ticket and get the
invoice these user needs depend on are
fulfilled by following components so you
have the schedule and speaker management
session ratings of a platform and
ticketing platform these are the
components that fulfill the user needs
directly and are very visible to you as
an attendee that you are interacting
directly with each of these components
needs to your own to store the the state
of your domain model so each of them
needs to have a data storage component
which is less visible to you as a user
since we would like to filter this
schedule by topical search to speak up a
name we might need to integrate in a
search engine that facilitate the
schedule and the speaker management each
of the the services of the management
components and the search engine data
storage has to run on kind of
environment where their software can be
executed the computer platform and this
computer form shall run on a virtual
machine so now we have identified the
first version of our value chain and now
we take this value chain and plotted
along their evolution axis
and the first draft could look like this
so we might decide that we have our
identified services that you and I
didn't that you're interacting directly
with it's custom-built components and we
might to use open source software for
search engine and data storage that goes
then in the product and rental evolution
stage and we decide to to run all of
them on being packaged as as docker
containers as a compute platform which
then will run on a cloud hosted virtual
machine we look at this worldly map and
we discuss it internally in the team and
we might come up with the decision that
the survey platform and the chicken
platform they do not really belong to
our core domain and that we would like
to use software as a service for those
two components and that for example that
we use surveys the serve survey as a
service and ticketing as a service that
we can move those components to from the
custom village to the product and a
rental evolution stage and that also
allows us to ignore all depending
components underneath because that's
something that the service supplier is
taking care of the evolution stages
itself themselves they help you to
identify what components to build
in-house where to use or buy
off-the-shelf products or open source
software and what components to
outsource to utility suppliers as I
mentioned in the beginning micro
services come with with infrastructure
and operational complexities so how can
they now be mapped out to the worldly
map and I would like to map them out
with under three different perspective
and let's start with the data related
perspective so with the data related
perspective we we said that we
going to use the search engine and the
data storage as open-source software and
if we run them on pram on premises we
need to we need to integrate or have
some activities that are related to
configuration backup recovery
maintenance scaling and monitoring
aspects and and yeah we also have to
integrate them into our services
the next perspective I would like to
bring in is the the what kind of
activities are relevant for our general
service activities the requirements that
we have so the service related
components and activities that are
general for every service is that we
have to provide a centralized
conservation management scaling recovery
metrics cover gathering location
distributed tracing monitoring aspects
and security aspects and capabilities
have to be considered the next
perspective after I've brought him like
data the general service perspective is
the service interaction related
components and activities so what kind
of service interaction types do we have
so we have can have requests driven
service interaction between our services
where our services are communicating
with with each other directly over their
API for example a REST API and we are
sending a command that leads to a state
change on the receiving service or
sending a Curie to retrieve data from
that service and for this request driven
service interaction we have to know the
location where the other service is
located so that we can connect and send
requests to that service and on another
aspect that we have to consider and this
will affect the activities is that a
request driven service interaction even
though it's really simple form of
integration and its introduced high
temporal coupling between those services
for example what happens when one
service is down so this will also
reflect some activities I will show you
in the next slide and then what I met
slide so that's the request driven
service interaction then we also have
the event-driven service interaction
where the services are not communicating
directly with each other
but instead they are communicating over
other messages of our events where we
have a message broker that services can
can publish their messages to and other
services can consume those events and
the the advantage of this service
interaction is that the consuming
services can handle these events
independently at their own pace and it
increased the decoupling between those
services and also the plug ability of
new consumers but it comes with a
downside that we have a separate
component the message broker oh you can
also have hybrid communication service a
communication where your services are
communicating via events but only for
notification purposes so those events
carry minimal data and in case another
service that subscribe and handles the
event needs additional data it does a
remote cross context query request
driven service call to the to the source
itself to retrieve additional data so
how what kind of activities do we have
to to map to the Wadley map related to
the request driven service interaction
and as I mentioned at first we have they
are communicating over an API so each
service has that is providing a request
an earth API for example have to provide
it and it requires the integration of
other services calling the service on
the other side since we our services are
needs to be located we have to provide
service discovery and load balancing and
also an API gateway for for external
requests due to the request driven
characteristics of high temporal
coupling we have to design for failure
to keep our system resilient and
introducing stability patterns such as
timeout retry circuit breaker bark heads
and idempotency as a consequence for the
event-driven and hybrid related
components and activities we have to
bring in an additional component the
message broker and as I mentioned before
the message broker if you run an
on-premise open source for example we
can use a RabbitMQ or a patchy Kafka if
you run it on on premise we have to
integrate it on the one side under our
services but also configure configure
them and activities are required such as
backup recovery maintenance and scaling
as we as I've described before if you
look at those activities that the
interest the infrastructure in
operational complexities and now look at
the Guardly map we have a lot of
activities that are not relevant that
are not related to our core domain and
that's something that we would like to
avoid and so we are starting to evolve
our value chain our technology stack
behind the first decision that we could
make is oh yeah we don't want to custom
build everything we don't want to
reinvent the wheel let's use as much
open-source software as possible so one
example I'm from the Java context itself
for example that you can use Netflix OSS
and spring cloud for for a circuit
breaker dynamic load balancing and
centralized configuration management you
can use for example Prometheus graph on
ax and BX tag that's elasticsearch lock
state and Cabana for all the
observability capabilities to cover like
metrics gathering dashboards lock
aggregation and distributed tracing
engine X you can use as some kind of
like
API gateway as a single point of entry
from the outside and with console you
can cover a service discovery themselves
security aspects for example and user
authentication and authorization could
be used by using the open source
Identity and Access Management solution
P cloak and for transport authentication
for your services service authentication
you can use vaults TLS certificate
certificate authentication itself so
what happens now was that we removed
those activities that we had first in
the first slide and the previous slide
as custom
we moved those components to the product
and rental product and rental evolution
stage and which is great so because we
are not we are not going to custom build
it but they are still very visible to us
that they might not be visible to the
user but they are very visible to us as
developers because first we have to
integrate them into our source code and
for example if we use libraries and
second if this is a service process that
is running we also have to configure
maintain and we provide some recovery
activities as well the next approach to
evolve our value chain is to use cloud
hosted services for for the search
engine the message broker and the data
storage component and offload those
related component of activity that are
related those to the cloud provider
itself
so moving vary the components from
product and rental to the commodity and
utility evolution stage helps us also to
that you can offload some of the
activities to the cloud providers
themselves as well so like backup
recovery maintenance scaling and so on
we don't have to take care of this
anymore but what still remains custom
built is the integration of these
components and also configure those
components as well so the next evolution
approach could be to to offload some of
the activities to a container
orchestration platform and with a
container orchestration platform our
micro services are packaged as
containers that are orchestrated yeah by
a platform that's preferably running on
top of a cloud hosted infrastructure and
contain orchestration such as one of the
most popular wan-koo benitez is taking
care of a lot of infrastructure and
operational complexities that without
ourselves being responsible and
integrating knowledge code but the
platform is taking care of it such as
recovery services
load-balancing centralized configuration
management scaling monitoring aspects
lock aggregation and so on also some
sort of API gateway from the outside so
within the kubernetes cluster our mics
are packaged as docker containers that
are running with an apart apart is a
group of one or more application
containers and that can also include a
volume a volume is a shared storage
providing for example file system access
or allow us to store configuration and
secret data and these in the service
themselves they are they are defines a
logical group of pots and enables
external traffic track exposure for
those pots and including service
discovery and load balancing and each
part is running in a worker nodes that
are controlled by a master node and the
nodes are working machines in kubernetes
for example cloud hosted virtual
machines and deployment defines the the
desired state of our of the of the
number of replicas of our pots and
automatically replaces any instance that
failed or became unresponsive and in
ingress enables to to provide an entry
point you into our clusters exposing our
hours services themselves from from the
outside so and how do this now look like
an equipment an award lei map so the
activities that I was describing which
abstracts which kubernetes for example
abstracts away such as service discovery
load balancing
lock aggregation and so on scaling and
recovery these activities have now moved
further down because that's something
that the orchestration platform is
taking care of but what comes you are
new primitives and resources that we now
as a developer has to take care of by
configuring them and not only these one
that I have described but a follow more
so it's not only few that that's them so
while the container operations such as
kubernetes are abstracting away a lot of
infrastructure and operational
complexities new primitives come to the
scene that we have to deal with by
configuring them so the committee
contained orchestration is offloading a
lot of things complexity too which is
great but with the trade-off that new
resources come to the scene that we have
to deal with so the next evolution step
could be to optimize the operability of
our mac service architecture by
abstracting away application application
networking reliability concerns and
introducing a service mesh a surface
mesh itself for example such as SEO is a
decentralized infrastructure that makes
our service to service communication
safe reliable and resilient and it's
it's what it does is that the the
services themselves they are not
communicating directly anymore but
instead through sidecar proxies and the
service mesh itself allows us to
abstract away these application
networking reliability concerns that we
had previously integrated into our
source code into our business searching
in turn and shift it to a service mesh
taking care of these these complexities
and so and it takes care of yeah
activities such as a circuit breaker
timeout retries distributed tracing and
so on and a service mesh touch assist
you is logically split into
a data plane in a control plane and the
data plane consists of a set of proxy
with for each service itself so the
service the the site it's called also
sidecar proxies because it sits next to
each service and it's running in the
same part as your micro service itself
and it's well and it's usually running
are typically running on top of
kubernetes
so the sidecar proxies they are
controlling and mediating every nest and
network communication between your
services along with the mixer and also
provides some built-in capabilities such
as circuit breaker and load balancing
and health checks themselves the mixer
is enforcing previously defined policy
for security aspects and also gathers
telemetry and the pilot itself that's
another component that comes with the
issue of service mesh that's providing
service discovery distribute the defined
policy to the proxies and also ensures
services curry and also introduced
stability patterns such as timeout
handling and retries and to make our
service to service communication secure
the Citadel takes care of that one and
also it's making the service of service
communication secure over TLS and also
rotates this certificate automatically
automatically so when we now look into
the ward limit we could have moved we
what we have moved is some of the custom
build and product and rental activities
to further down into the product and
rental evolution stage because now the
application network reliability
activities are now handled by the
service mesh itself but as also as the
same with who vanitas it comes with its
own resources so while it's tucked away
activities it comes with new resources
that we have to deal with
so while continued orchestration such as
kubernetes or service message touches is
to you obstructing away a lot of
interest
action operational complexities comes
with new comes with new resources that
we have to deal with
we might so as the next evolution stage
we might have we don't mean white we
have the the desire not to manage
everything by ourselves or to to handle
the kubernetes cluster at and including
the service mesh we might decide to we
would like to have our infrastructure
fully managed by a cloud provider by
introducing serverless
technologies service and in the context
of in the contiguous function as a
service is allows you that you have no
service to manage your provision and
they're still servers in the background
but it's not on your responsibility to
manage those instead the infrastructure
is fully managed by your cloud provider
and in this context of Solus was
function as a service your function is
now the the unit of work in a function
is yes it's a fine-grained short-lived
function that is triggered through a
variety of events events could be an
HTTP event or could be in a database
event inserting a row into your database
table could also be a file upload or
some some messaging advances as well as
well and these functions that you have
to find are automatically scaled
dynamically by usage so it could scale
the cloud provider can scale use
functions up but also to scale them down
to two zero and the only pay for
execution that means if a function gets
idle it shuts down and cost nothing but
also several as with the context of
function as a service comes also with
new primitives and these are very cloud
specific so I will demonstrate one
example with AWS and they come with
their own building blocks where you can
build your years
beckoned API for example but using a lot
of building blocks that you're wiring
together with your lambda function and I
will create another example of a service
solution that is related to our
conference solution as well so we are
now focusing on the speaker s users and
they might have the user need to submit
a CFP a call for paper and containing
there are top details but also their bio
descriptions and for that purpose we are
providing an N rest endpoint that is
exposed by an API gateway that triggers
a lambda function that will take this
request validates it and saves its
result into a DynamoDB table whenever a
new entry in the Denali DynamoDB table
has been inserted it will trigger in
another function that sends out an email
to the conference organizers as a simple
form of notification the speaker would
also like to upload their profile
picture and for that purpose we are
communicating with this s3 bucket where
we can upload our profile picture to and
this whenever we upload a new picture
and it will trigger another function
that updates the meta information of our
CFP or of our profile picture into the
database the organizer then after you
have submitted the CP Everest has
received this confirmation the ceases
and received the email about the about
the new cfp entry and she would like to
to receive the CFP to read it so for
that purpose we are providing another
rest endpoint that is exposed by an api
gateway that retrieves that reads the
data from the dynamodb table and returns
it to the organizer to the client itself
and
in the main and also you would like to
the the organizer would like to confirm
the CFP and for that point for that case
we are calling another function over a
REST API that confirms the CFP and
updates the status of the CFP in the
DynamoDB table and on the one side but
also some published some message to and
as an S topic to which two other
functions are subscribing to or have
subscribed to sending out an email to
the speaker that their that their CFP
has been accepted but also another
another function that updates see if bt
tales or the talk details was in the
schedule management for creating the
schedule the organiser can create the
schedule function that saves the the end
the schedule itself and the in the table
which triggers another function that
updates elasticsearch index and finally
at the end us and it indeed would like
to treat to get the schedule and for
that we have a rest endpoint that its
supposed by the api gateway that
triggers a get scheduled function
retrieving the data details from from
the dynamodb table so as you can see we
have we are using the lambda functions
as representing your code your your
domain logic and we are using the in
this case AWS building blocks for data
storage but also for wiring wiring our
our lambda functions together so how
does it now look in our water map so
since now we have we don't have to take
care of a community discussed instead we
get our infrastructure fully managed by
the cloud provider and that means that
the all the activities that we had to
deal with before in custom build and
product and rental are now shifted to
the commodity and utility evolution
stage because that's something that the
cloud provider is now taking care of and
so the the integration of those of those
AWS functions are is by implementing
those functions and yeah we are using
then the the common building blocks as
using them to viral them together as a
confirmation aspect itself and so it
allows us to shift away a lot of
activities and components to the
commodity and utility evolution stage on
top of that
AWS also provides the surveillance
application repository that allows you
to to deploy and share and build common
pre-built serverless components for
example a pre-built service component
for generating an image some nail that
you can use that you can use in your
several aspects and as well or you're
updating your elasticsearch index for
example could also be a pre-built
service component and by what the
service technologies allows you is that
it enables innovation because the
efficiency the industrialization of all
the activities and components that we
have addressed before and moving it to
the evolutions commodity and utility
evolution stage allows us to enable
innovation for example that we can add
new features of our existing components
or for example that we can also create a
new component that has not existed
before in our context and abling new
user needs so there are different
several s infrastructure providers
beside the one that I was displaying was
AWS also from yeah from the the major
cloud providers themselves and they also
open-source solutions available as well
because one thing that also it's every
technology stack that that you are using
or that you're deciding to use it comes
with benefits but also was trade-off so
also when you go for a cloud provided
service it's just great because it gets
fully managed and it
so you focus too on your codomain but
comes with building blocks that are very
cloud provide a specific and that bears
the risk that you enter yet that you
goes into the vendor lock and problem
and if this is not a problem for you
then it's fine but it might be a problem
for you and then also there are open
source solutions available that are
cloud agnostic and one one thing that I
would like to point out is K native
that's kubernetes extension that allows
you to extend for surveillance workloads
that you can can provide and to to get
it run on on any environment where
kubernetes is running and underneath so
in the end no matter what kind of
technologies that we are we are choosing
or deciding to use we still have two the
first thing that we have to focus on is
are we fulfilling user and business
needs because that's the one that is
necessary for our business and we need
to focus on our core domain because
that's the one that is giving us
competitive advantage and this is
generating fulfilling our user needs and
also generating visible user values
leading to satisfied customers and the
the core domain that's the one that we
should strategically invest in most
that's the one that we should build
in-house and to be able to do that we
have to identify the commodities and
outsource them to the utility supplier
because in the end we don't want to
custom-built commodities because that's
wasting a lot of time and put energy in
something that is abstracting away or
that is shifting you focus away from
from building your core domain and yeah
we definitely have to continuously adapt
and otherwise we get can't we can get
overtaken by others and Wadley Maps
helps you to visualize how can you how
you can evolve your value chain and it's
under lying technology stack its itself
so in the end we would like to build a
product that is usable usable and
fulfill our users needs and not a
product which took a very long time to
build
is very expensive and even not usable in
this case so thank you for listening
[Applause]